hey Paul yeah he's a snazzy dress man
really well now he's got now he's got
reason to be have to be right yes I know
right is that is that one of Paul Feig
he's got we all know Paul Feig from s as
a filmmaker and everything but you've
got a line of suits yes I do at J crew
is that one of the sue this is one of
the suits yes amazing thank you so much
does it come with the flower and the
handkerchief you can buy those
separately those both complement each
other it's so amazing how how did they
look together I appreciate that thank
you so much he's trying to each trying
to connect with you on a fashion line
[Laughter]
it's fun for me I wear them all the time
and thought why not make make them in my
style that I like yeah you are you're a
very nicely dressed guy i'll say that
you are last time you came in though
yeah when did you when did you start
deciding like I'm gonna be that guy who
wears suits all the time and like you
know what as a kid I did it because
Groucho Marx is my hero yeah and I read
a biography about him when I was a kid
and it's been super popular like going
to school in suits you had to say no no
it's for Groucho as the fist was coming
he said that he'd never trusted a man
who didn't dress up so I thought well I
have to dress up and just kind of caught
on and when I was in like 20s as a
stand-up when Doug and I used to work
together in the variety arts club I was
in my vintage bowling shirt clothing
line made out of hemp so you're a
Groucho fan yeah huge so you're a little
young to have been like a big Groucho
not that you don't say like that's
timeless but usually guys in our age
group are kinda late whether stirrers a
prior or yeah I mean I loved all them as
stand-ups that what happened was when I
was about eight or nine they reissued
animal crackers in theatres and so my
mom took me in like during the afternoon
we went and it was packed with college
kids and the place went crazy I mean
they just went nuts and so that was just
kind of magical moment where you go oh
my God look at this thing it was cool
somebody that you know is a young young
person you could discover somebody that
your peers didn't know so that was
always already watched - none of them
knew kind of known to pay attention yeah
exactly it's not some old
black-and-white things you know I always
try to stay it's funny I discovered
Steve Martin before anybody knew who he
was and I memorized his first album and
would go to school and recite it but I'd
recited as if I had written it sure yeah
so you were the first person to discover
Steve Mart like nobody knew you were in
Michigan yeah yes not he had not caught
on he had just been doing Saturday live
a little bit in the first element just
come out and so more the first album
called
let's get small I was first so when you
when when the kids find out that like
you're just reciting an album yeah yeah
like it's a you must have had an
unpleasant time is it cause I did oh
stole a comedy operas pretending it's
him
the weird kid is actually funny oh no
he's not he just stole all this or it
was one oh what a few months I have one
of the genes think Steve Martin did was
wear the white suit because they said it
was like where he used to dressed crazy
or you and they said it just it fit it
was a two on the nose and then wearing a
white suit was such a different thing
than the way he was acting that was what
kind of put put it together
yeah and that sort of came full circle
for me with the suits and everything to
the point where I was such a nerd
I I was all over that album I went to
RadioShack and I bought a microphone and
a mic stand and I bought a three-piece
white suit of the disco store and we put
it on every night close my door and
recite the album into the microphone
every night for months that's how I knew
it so well boys your favorite boys your
favorite joke oh I like the whole thing
I'm so mad at my taking the bar bells I
make my grandmother don't worry go she
wanted to borrow $10 for some food so
you put a white suit on in your room yes
and do Steve Martin by myself yes
[Laughter]
just pretend Steve Martin's giving you a
hand did you ever tell him that story I
finally got to meet with him I had a
meeting with him in his house about a
project and was so nervous I wanted to
tell him in the minute I started to try
to say something about it he was like he
cut it off immediately like he just he
seems like he just doesn't want to hear
any like but he Fanning over him would
really understand what did he say oh no
that's right he's like oh yeah yeah so
anyway okay so but is that kind of a
bummer though for you you're like I've
kind of spent all this time building to
this and like it means so much to me but
you're totally over it no I kind of get
it because he's such a superstar yeah I
actually I had a really bad experience
with Steve Martin a few years before
that I was doing a TV show and one of
the other actors on it was a Tom Arnold
show and Michael boatman this great
actor Michael Bowman was on there too
and we got asked to do to a reading of
my fellow Americans that they're trying
to cast and they're trying to get Steve
Martin to do it so the producer put
together this giant reading at his house
all these really famous actors there and
Steve basically kind of to hopefully
romance him into doing it so he shows up
he's reading the thing and he's
hilarious I mean we're just cracking up
and cracking up but he I think felt like
he was being conned a little bit so
you'd look around at us sort of with
this look of like you know you know that
wasn't as funny as you guys are acting
so he's were in the middle of the
reading and he's in the middle of this
long speech Michael Bowman sitting next
to me we're sitting across from Steve
and all of a sudden for some reason
Michael boatman in the middle of his
speech goes wrong and just does this
like I'm falling asleep thing Steve
Martin looks up from his grip and looks
directly at me look like he wants to
kill me and I'm frozen and then he goes
back to reading I just look over Michael
I [ __ ] did you just do a I don't know I
thought be funny and so in they're gonna
laugh no especially not from Steve and
he thought it was you
ya thought it was me and he laughed for
years I was walking around like oh my
god Steve Martin hey did you ever tell
him I didn't snore during the speech
think I actually have that meeting I
remind him of the time that somebody
snorted species yes a bad mood anyway
you look at you as an equal if you're in
his house he has to go this guy is in
equal and I'm gonna do a project so if
you're fanboying out he's then all the
sudden he's like I can't it's hard for
him to look at you as an equal
yeah I totally get that that's why it
was kind of like oh cool I felt weird
that I tried to bring it on I have not
no but I've talked to people who were
way above me and showbusiness was a lot
of them everybody in the room but you
wind up realizing that they don't need a
fanboy out yeah you probably like that
with DeNiro
yeah I didn't family out I mean I I
wanted to inside but I was actually
comfortable oddly comfortable yeah you
don't want a fanboy out in front of
genero you might wake him fly died on
his face I spent the night with him I
wants to fly crawl up a drape it's hard
to kind of act normal around people you
add my famous I have a horrible time
sometimes you're so nervous I did with
him I was just I was talking about
staying up so it was easier but it's so
over the top nervous that you go you you
beat you can full circle into I'm so
petrified I'm calm yeah like it's like
if I dialed it back one inch I would
have been a blathering [ __ ] [ __ ]
right but it was so overwhelming and
surreal that you just feel like you're
not this is not even happening yeah and
you're comfortable yeah if you really
can't because I don't know if you saw
the opening of Jim special but narrow
spanked his bare ass hilarious and I
would imagine it would be very difficult
to like fanboy out over somebody and
then be like hey also I was thinking
would you want to say but you you're
doing something anything what you want
to do this you like yeah let's just do
it's like it's so overwhelming one who
you fan Boyd I'm sure you cuz you've
worked a lot of big famous people well
the probably famous people well no I I
tend to go the opposite way and try to
act too cool or I go nuts and so I've
had so many bad encounters for somebody
I really admire Tom Ford I think he's
like the greatest and I've been at a
number of events where he's at good
cologne yeah good cologne exact nice
sunglasses and I always go egged on this
like three times with him I walk
I'm a big fan and I'm gonna get in your
way and I just say hi and I walk away
like a crazy and every time he sees me
coming now it's a god here comes that
weirdo but I had the dumbest thing ever
happened he was I was at a party years
ago I was a regular on the Gary it's
Garry Shandling show and they did this
big final party and George Wendt was
married to one of the actors actresses
on the show huge George Wendt and he
comes up to me and I tried to act so
cool cuz I'm so nervous he I think
you're great on the show I'm a really
big fan I'm just like oh my god it's
George Wendt I make the decision to hold
my hand out and do this look like and
you are Andy George went and shook my
hand he walked away like this look like
what it is
why'd I do that I do that and so like
two hours later before he left I won't
run over to him of a dance form like
George I'd want to say I'm big fan he's
like yeah did the Fritos commercials did
he yeah I say so
oh well he went you know from from
cheers he D do Fritos also oh no Fritos
exactly comic from years ago he was
talking about I'm a big fan he was of an
old comic that did freedom I was a big
fan of Groucho so so why wouldn't he be
stop gesturing with your glasses
sunshine boys remember you ever the
movie with Walter Matthau transitioning
Frenchie's yeah funny movie he's
auditioning do you see Glass Castle no I
did not we were discussing how great it
is what's your future for my newest
movie produce that so I'll tell him that
was newest movie it's coming out next
year it's called a simple favor with
Anna Kendrick and Blake Lively it's a
thriller a fun thriller and uh it's very
fun what do you think I mean obviously
it's disheartening but like you know is
your work been affected although it's
been going on like certain people you
can't work with now or actors or
actresses or not every time you can
somebody you have to panic like like
Ridley Scott just kind of took Kevin
Spacey out of a movie right yeah I mean
I'm lucky because I work with so many
women so there's
so far they've been clean but uh I don't
know you you don't really I don't you
can't really factor that in a let look
whenever I work with anybody I always do
kind of a check around the town to find
out if they're an [ __ ] and so
generally that'll fall into the same
category so I've been really lucky
though see all you do check around the
you you said seven houses worked with
this person Heiser hey life's too short
to be stuck for months what do you do if
you stuck with somebody on the set who
you don't like it's usually it's the
directors like you'll ask the actors
what do you do if there's a director
who's a screamer what do you have you
I'm sure you don't actors we just don't
want to take direction yeah I've had a
couple it's been worse
it was worse in television because
you're sort of a hired hand who comes in
and there's the cast who've been there
and a lot of them sometimes just have
this thing of like alright [ __ ] you
you're this guy you know who's this is
our job every day and you're coming in
right it's a guest but I've been pretty
lucky I only had a couple of bad
experiences how do you handle it you
just kind of put your head down and get
through it because what it is is a lot
of times you're trying to get them to do
something they don't want to do that the
producers want you to get them to do and
so it's your job to make it happen no
matter what and you know everyone's well
I just like look they want you to do
this I know what to tell you and some
think they'll usually come around I mean
what happens once the camera rolls
people usually pull it together because
nobody wants a bad performance so you'll
tell them like after a while like look
this is not me they asked me to tell you
to do this and it's up to you if you
don't do it that that's my last resort
if I if I'm trying to get them to do
something that I don't believe in
because that's a lot of times like the
producers like you gotta come to say
that something like that's a really dumb
joke or that's not right or that's not
their voice and that's what I'll just
resort your look it's not yeah but if
you're doing like three or four takes
can you say hey just try it this way
we're not gonna go call do it for single
that yeah but they get pretty smart
about that you're like oh sure okay I
give you the one take and then that's
what you just do this one for safety and
you know that's the movie one of the
actors who was a little over the top I
always go let's just do a small one for
safety and then then they saw the movie
that was the entire movie was a small
you know I believe they left the
premiere
there well the small it takes worked for
the film right Oh total which is a
comedy or a drama it was a comedy okay
you know it just made or female I'm not
going to say anymore
how many Paul Feig comedy it's pretty
easy to narrow down its female why I
feel you've worked with so many women
though had you heard like at least
rumblings or these stories that Lake I
think a lot of people were kind of
shocked when the Weinstein thing starts
and then it snowballs into know it's
happening across no I mean there's
definitely there's definitely kind of a
group of names you would hear over and
over again who had bad reputations the
weird thing about Harvey was because I
almost worked with him I had a project
with him that I ended up not doing
because I just felt like life was too
short had enough people tell me it was
more like Marlon Wayans was like don't
do it it's not worth it well we're
dealing with him yeah you a movie with
him he'd had bad experiences with him
but I had only heard what a what a jerk
he was and how hard he was to work with
I had somehow not heard the sexual story
oh thank god they won't wear one of your
suits when that homeboy that's the
biggest scary thing now with as a kid
suits with shorts no I never did that
but that's the angers gonna be a secure
person to pull that up great legs
Bermuda in Australia a lot of people
where's the Angus Young yeah yeah did
you guys at 12
check the website when when Tom Ford
reaches this other level of popularity
because of the jay-z song like and he
doesn't become just a guy that people
know in fashion but like a pop-culture
name that people know are you the type
of guy that goes like no you guys aren't
aren't the real calm for fans I've known
him forever or do you not care no I I
you know I want everybody to succeed who
I think is great
yeah but I'm currently trying to get a
rap artist to mention my new line yes
the J Crew zoo line yes exactly I think
they could wrap a good policy for J Crew
the suit was a j.crew suit roughly cost
like what's that what's the range that
they start at the rate I owe the range
is like the jacket is right around the
400 range and the pants like 200 so you
can get you get a full suit for like 800
bucks which is you should you should
have up this with it you get a celebrity
to wear the suit and then you charge
like $7,000 for it yes and that is if
you want okay yeah if you want if you
want to advertise 220 people do you make
them in Torf how are you anal retentive
about the about the suits like are you
like very detail-oriented yeah I'm what
they call well even with my own suit I'm
what they call a wrinkle chaser which
doesn't mean I'd go after old ladies but
I'll go to like the tailor like four or
five times just because oh this thing's
wrong or this is wrong oh you go back yo
I just throw it out I go one time I had
my [ __ ] dwarfee little arms short
sleeves taken up and if it doesn't fit
they goes right in the bin Jim come on
you gotta you gotta get in there that's
their job they have to do it perfect
[Laughter]
what are you wearing I'm wearing it
right now yeah I'm very anti casual
front if you want to see Paul Feig not
wearing a suit I've been obsessed with
the movie heavyweights probably since it
came out and I watch it like multiple
times a year every year nice but you can
see Paul in a pair of like short shorts
and a half tee yeah exactly what you
popped up wait hold on they just found
these really Detroit gold Paul Feig
t-shirt and the t-shirt that came up is
who you gonna call not Paul don't call
it I gotta get some of those that's
that's antastic
were you set you know in hindsight you
know it doesn't anymore
terone was happening it was kind of a
bummer just was you know we didn't we
didn't make it as right piss people off
we made it to kind of make people laugh
and all that and then it turned into
such a thing yeah amuses me like you're
still mad about it a year and a half out
then you got bigger problems did you
want it to be a political thing like is
that because maybe when you you just
wanted to make a comedy but casting all
women obviously that's going to be a
thing that people take note of it was
that a I never thought it'd be a thing
just because I all I do is work with
funny ladies right now when they wanted
me to do when I was like oh perfect I
can use all these funny women that I
know and that's literally the the extent
of what I thought and it's the internet
and still like things like I was on
something political mission and all I
think it affected the the movie or the
the box office or that or do you think
there was just a lot of bad you know
there's a lot of bad press about the bad
reaction that the these guys had to us
yes and all their down voting of the the
trailer and stuff so yeah it didn't help
but um you know look the movie is what
it is and then it's so many women and
girls especially like really loved it
and it's inspired a lot of a lot of
women to go into science and all that so
I stand by it I love it personally if
people don't like something that's one
thing but it's when they think they know
what your motives are you people go hey
I didn't like that movie of sucked okay
you didn't like it or I don't like that
joke but when they think they know why
you did it yeah that's the frustrating
point Oh totally you know you guys deal
with it all time like you have a joke to
defend somebody's like I know why you
said that
now it's yeah but look I mean that's
that's the power and the fun and the
terribleness of the internet which is
everybody has a strong opinion that they
can put out there but it's great I'd
rather I'd rather have that but not have
it but you know it just sometimes a
little disheartening sure how did how
did the actresses take it like cuz I
mean I think that the argument that you
put Kate McKinnon in a comedy because
you wanted to make a great comedy is a
pretty solid argument yeah she's one of
the funniest people on television and
stuff but how did they take it when now
they get lumped into this this thing
that now they're in another political
argument yeah I mean they were pretty
cool about it I mean you know Kay
especially like Kate and Kristen just
completely avoid the internet they don't
have any social media or anything really
so yeah they only think they're aware
you know Melissa's just a rock star so
she doesn't Karen Leslie
you know if I could warrior so she you
know if you'd say to me I sometimes
apologize I'm sorry that's going on
she's like you think I [ __ ] care you
know so she's just you know she is the
coolest
yeah the old weather did fine not being
aware the Internet would kind of be I I
envy people who literally don't care
about being online yeah I get addicted
to this it's stupid just click click
click for what I know how many times
that you just every day is like put the
[ __ ] phone down like it's it becomes
this weird addiction sort of pattern of
like ok I'll check over here wait now I
gotta checking with Twitter no I gotta
check CNN but it's hard not to check
though and like all of a sudden when
you're growing up we had I literally
remember party lines we would have a
party line and I remember the idea we
would fantasize about someday being able
to talk and see the person on the phone
you were talking to we would talk about
that like yeah someday you'll have a
monitor in your kitchen and now you
could just face tight it's it's it's
overwhelming I can't handle it oh no
it's crazy although when I was a kid I
used to have angst about because they
were always like the Jetsons or
something they have this is the phone
where you could see somebody I feel like
oh god I don't want that because the
phone time is the only time you can kind
of talk and kind of look around or make
a face like I'm whatever idiot so now
you've got to perform while you're on
that I don't know I can't FaceTime it's
too much pressure
yeah I'm fine type in FaceTime are hard
because you have to focus on the person
yeah and it's like being in real it's
like I would rather just [ __ ] do do
20 different things and text you it's
much easier right and you can't talk of
a toilet so when you when you start
working on this new project is it like
does the studio get apprehensive about
like okay but we know what the paul feig
thing is now it became a thing last time
so now it's like always doing another
one of these lady movies like what's
know I mean they they're they're fine
with that I mean I I'm lucky that I'm
one of the few people that actually can
just get any any movie made if it's a
good script with you know with a female
cast yeah no you know I mean this it was
kind of what it was what it was and how
is this movie going to ruin men's
childhood oh so many ways was picked on
in school so now he wants to make sure
that all you that had good
childhoods Jess sweets gonna squash it
all but I mean I think that you know on
the studio thing my movie you know not
to brag but my movies have made over a
billion dollars worldwide so thank you
so much I only say that because they
star women and you know that the excuse
that floats around has floated around
for years is that you know movies with
women don't make that much money and
look at what just happen with Wonder
Woman so that's right yeah Take Back the
Night well you know super are you
donating a procede piece the proceeds
the handkerchiefs are going to stomp out
bullying yeah so what will you bully
physically or is it just like the things
they would say uh both really I had a
couple of bullies in particular who were
half my size and the locker room was
their particular fun place to really
give me a hard time and they would they
would want to attack you when your name
is Feig you can only imagine journey to
another yeah my friend bill Knox Tucker
got the same restaurant called suckers I
guess that kind of uh you know it's did
you ever see those people later in life
where they're like hey I'm a big fan and
you're like no you know I remember you
know fortunately I haven't run into
those bullies just cuz I've separated
myself for my my home state of Michigan
but I know that one day they will show
up and would you still hate them or did
you ever did you ever kind of come
together with them before that did you
speak to them growing up at all no no no
it was always bad and I don't know if
they came up and like apologized I would
forgive them in a heartbeat but I was
thinking practice gonna come up just
call me the same name and punch me or
something somebody I know I'm scarred
yeah yeah I know I know somebody was
sexually abused when like years ago I
push 4050 years ago and he's a kid and
we talked about it and he goes yeah I
saw the guy he came up to me the guy was
a fan at that point no and he goes I
said what you say - because I was scared
of him yeah like as a 50 or 60 year old
man he was scared of this other man
because of those memories when he was a
kid
as a radio host as he come to grips with
it I know but I'm trying to think of how
to do I address that or do I just allow
that one too late clenching his hands
surprised over this summer when Dean
Ackroyd started taking kind of shots out
of nowhere I was like it kind of felt
like I get why Dan Aykroyd would be a
loyalist kind of to ghostbusters but you
would I just didn't understand he was
saying things that weren't even true
about the numbers yeah box office and it
was a bummer just because I'm such a
huge damn fan and I will continue to be
I love Dan and we had such a nice time
on the movie I get it like you know
that's a huge brand for them and it
didn't you know didn't do it was
supposed to and I you know I think it
might have you know it's made it harder
to get another one going so I completely
get why he'd be upset but Dan if you're
out there I love you and you know Dan if
you're out there and you're like that
upset that the Ghostbusters isn't
continuing on you could move beyond
Ghostbuster or Dan way do you hear about
the the all-female doctor Detroit yes oh
he just got mad that he thought it hurt
the franchise in like for his own thing
yeah I am he was on a radio show and
vodka vodka wine is quite good let's go
yeah like that the movie wasn't
profitable which wasn't true if you look
at this box office mojo and he said that
like the retakes on the movie cost like
40 million dollars yes because Paul
wasn't listening and then they were like
no it's actually it was 2 to 3 million
was our it was our reshoot shoot we just
had to shoot some extra stuff for to add
a couple scenes but you know it's all
it's so funny that a year and a half ago
the movie came out and it still still
has a life on the internet you want it
you'd want to believe that at some point
like that would all just go away and
people would just be able to figure out
whether or not they liked
movie I know exactly where somebody do
the all chimp version of The Godfather
that will get me out of trouble so you
have it so cute yeah I would like be
first in line yeah you see Jack Walsh
just bouncing the Horsehead having fun
you are but that's the last thing you
did now you doing a thriller it's like
did you haven't done a movie since gross
right no no no but do you feel like you
after that do you normally wait that
long in between films are usually a
two-year with things yeah my movies tend
to come out every two years because it
was only spy and ghostbusters were a
year apart just because when I was just
finished spy this came up and so we
slammed right into it but usually it's
two years so now you're doing a thriller
what how much different is that
obviously it's their comedy it's it's
everything different it's super fun I
mean you know I like everything to have
have a funny element to it but I loved
this script got sent to me I have a deal
at Fox and they wanted us to produce at
my company and when I read it I loved it
so much because it's kind of
Hitchcockian but it's also a really
funny main character of this really
nerdy mom who has like a mommy vlog that
she does and then she gets caught in
this really odd situation and to me I
thought like oh I love anything about
like sort of nerds or people kind of out
of place who then get thrust into it you
know a new situation and so it just
seemed like the kind of an easy
transition it was just nice to not do a
movie that is just hard like jokes every
every minute because we were able to
concentrate on the characters in the
story but that's that it's really it's
really fun and Anna Kendrick is
unbelievable she's she's such an amazing
comedic talent but such a great actress
- and then Blake Lively plays the
villain and she's just she embraces it
with quite a gusto I think people gonna
be surprised were you a horror movie
geek at all knowing up for yes you
chicken didn't go that way I was too
chicken III it's funny I would love to
make a horror movie because it's really
fun to be in control of it but to watch
something that I don't know what's gonna
happen next I get really tense although
I do love thrillers but I was on too
squeamish like anything with a knife
going through me like oh I can't but
that's one of the things that's so cool
about spy is it even though it's Melissa
McCarthy comedy when it's violent it's
very violent yeah yeah and and and a
thing that I think is missing from
why James Bond movies are still so
genteel like your movies so much more
fun than the most recent James Bond
movies well thanks oh you know what it
is is because we just go are and they
have to keep those pg-13 just because
yeah they think it's gonna hurt me but I
you know look at Deadpool how well that
did yeah I think you can go that way
I love r-rated comedy not because you
know you know my movies they don't
really have any nudity your sex scenes
in them to speak of but I just like
people being able to be honest with
their language and to be able to swear
and then on top of it you know when you
have violence you want to have it be
real I mean like it in the heat we've
got a shot of this guy get like shot in
the head and it's it's really it's
pretty brutal but you know that's why I
loved remember of Beverly Hills Cop when
that first came out that wasn't like an
opening scene as well yeah they execute
some guy in a hallway remember just like
you know when I went to see that coming
like holy [ __ ] I thought this is a
comedy but then I really cared about the
you know the guys like they could get
killed and that to me that's what really
raises the stakes